Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Reinforcement learning is a technique where
we have a virtual creature that tries to learn
an optimal set of actions to maximize a reward
in a changing environment.
Playing video games, helicopter control, and
even optimizing light transport simulations
are among the more awesome example use cases
for it.
But if we train a reinforcement learner from
scratch, we'll see that it typically starts
out with a brute force search in the space
of the simplest, lowest level actions.
This not only leads to crazy behavior early
on, but is also highly ineffective, requires
way more experience than humans do, and, the
obtained knowledge cannot be reused for similar
tasks.
It can learn the game it was trained on, often
even on a superhuman level, but if we need
it to function in a new environment, all this
previous knowledge has to be thrown away.
And this algorithm is very much like how humans
learn - it breaks down a big and complex task
into sequences of smaller actions.
These are called sub-policies and can be shared
between tasks.
Learning to walk and crawl are excellent examples
of that and will likely be reused for a variety
of different problems and will lead to rapid
learning on new, unseen tasks, even if they
differ significantly from the previously seen
problems.
Not only that, but the search space over sub-policies
can easily be a hundred or more times smaller
than the original search space of all possible
actions, therefore this kind of search is
way more efficient than previous techniques.
Of course, creating a good selection of sub-policies
is challenging, because they have to be robust
enough to be helpful on many possible tasks,
but not too specific to one problem, otherwise
they lose their utility.
A few episodes ago, we mentioned a related
technique by the name Neural Task Programming,
and it seems that this one is capable of generalization
not only over different variations of the
same task, but across different tasks as well.
These ants were trained to traverse several
different mazes one after another and quickly
realized that the basic movement directions
should be retained.
Creating more general learning algorithms
is one of the holy grail problems of AI research,
and this one seems to be a proper, proper
step towards defeating it.
We're not there yet, but it's hard not to
be optimistic with this incredible rate of
progress each year.
Really excited to see how this area improves
over the next few months.
The source code of this project is also available.
Oh, and before we go, make sure to check out
the channel of Robert Miles who makes excellent
videos about AI, and I'd recommend starting
with one of his videos that you are objectively
guaranteed to enjoy.
If you wish to find out why, you'll see the
link in the video description or just click
the cat picture appearing here on the screen
in a moment.
If you indeed enjoyed it, make sure to subscribe
to his channel.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!